There were 70 million of these dropped by
allied air force, the American airport.
And it's gives the name of 12 different cities.
It says we have a bomb that has more powerful.
That is more powerful than all of the weaponry.
We have dropped in Europe in one bomb.
If you're in one of these 12 cities, Nagasaki, and Hiroshima,
where two of those cities, please leave now.
Couple of other things.
Because I think change history, you know what this is.
I mean, this it's gotta be well, there's Japanese markings on there, right?
So this is, Oh God, well, that's not dropping. No,
it's certainly not the dropping of the nukes.
Okay. But that's what this is about. Yeah. Okay. The back. Okay.
There were 70 million of these dropped by
allied air force, the American airport.
And it's gives the name of 12 different cities.
It says we have a bomb that has more powerful.
That is more powerful than all of the weaponry.
We have dropped in Europe in one bomb.
If you're in one of these 12 cities, Nagasaki, and Hiroshima,
where two of those cities, please leave.
Now if your country,
what if your emperor will not surrender? We will be left with no choice,
but it is so horrific.
Please take food and water and clothing and leave the cities.
We're not targeting you. Please leave.
Those supplies will be in very short supply. Afterwards,
you were shot. If you picked one up, wow,
what country tells their people? We're coming.
We have this bomb. We're going to drop it by this date.
And it's going to happen in one of these cities.
Well, there's one country that does it now,
but the left is not thrilled with that country. Right?
One. Yeah. How come we don't know about that?
Every time we hear about America is so bad,
they always bring up the atomic bomb. Well, can you throw this?
Oh, this is incredible. Yeah. Uh.
This is an original letter to the Hitler youth from Neville Chamberlain.
Um, this talks about, um,
I welcomed the intention of the German youth movement to devote a special, uh,
issue of the magazine, uh, to, uh,
your ideals in it. He talks about he's met with the fewer.
He w he's a man of peace and, uh.
Germany are set upon you to Hitler.
Youth Neville, Chamberlain.
That one I got just because I appeasement never,
ever works.
Listen to the last line. I mean, I know you've read it,
but the admirable motto of the year of understanding,
which you have chosen for the year of 1938 shows the part that you are playing
in this work. I mean, talk about appeasement and confusion. Yep.
Wow.
Well, of other things, this is wonderful. Read it.
Okay.
I,
Ronald Reagan do solemnly swear that I will faithfully execute the office of the
president of the United States and will to the best of my ability preserve,
protect, and defend the constitution of the United States. So help me, God,
Ronald Reagan, January 20th, 1980.
And on the top two Nancy who brightens the, uh,
is it the corner who Britons, who brightens,
brightens the corner where we are? Yeah. Wow.
That's the one, that's the one, that's the one.
Right in front of him as he was taking the oath of office.
And how many people,
how many people really mean that mean those words.
Um, have you ever heard of, uh, uh, Colonel stone?
Uh, he was a guy. Um, he was, um,
military, actually the guy who, uh,
first protected,
kind of our first secret service agent first protected Abraham Lincoln when he
was coming in to, uh, Washington for the very first time. He's the guy who,
who said, we gotta get you out. We're going to have you go into a theater.
We're going to have you change clothes.
You're going to hunch over like a little old lady.
And we're going to get you out the back into a carriage.
And we're going to get you on train, take you to Pittsburgh,
because everybody's going to think that you're going to Washington.
We'll get you to Pittsburgh. They will take another train into Washington.
And no one will know it saved his life, saved his life. He became,
uh, a Colonel in, um, the, uh, Northern army in the fight,
in the civil war. And he refused to hate the other side.
He just thought they were wrong, but he refused to hate them.
That caused a lot of problems with a lot of politicians because they were
whipping up the hate. It's why, uh, Lincoln's,
vice-president walked out and was so upset. It's why we have a picture of,
uh,
the only picture that is of John Wilkes booth and Abraham Lincoln
in the same picture and booth is behind him.
And it's at the second inaugural address.
And he actually tried to kill him there because he was so enraged that this guy
would say, let's come together. Let's heal these wounds.
He was enraged by that and really wanted to kill him with his own hands and
attempted to do it. Well. Um, uh,
this Colonel became a Colonel in the civil war.
He was for something that he never did.
It was a trumped up charge because he became very unpopular with, with, uh,
Congress, Congress, uh, tried him.
He wasn't allowed to even put on a defense.
He wasn't allowed to speak in front of Congress.
They never came to a verdict because they know that it would have been,
he would have been set free. So he was held, um, in prison.
He was held in prison. And I think for about six months,
Lincoln found out about it and said, what the hell are you doing? Charge him,
convict him, or let him go. And, uh, they didn't,
they waited another six or eight months.
Lincoln found out about it again and just said, get him out. He was so upset.
He went over,
he left the United States and he went over and he was working for the French in
Egypt, years later, he comes back. He's thinking,
he's hoping everybody is going to forget about those things that they said about
him. He's at home. He gets a knock on the door. No one will hire him.
They do remember no one will hire him. He opens up the door,
it's two representatives from the United States government. And they said,
Colonel, we understand you were in Egypt and you were working with the French.
And he said, yes. And, uh, they said,
so do you speak and read French? Yes.
Good.
Cause we just got a big box of stuff and we don't know how to put it together.
It was the statue of Liberty. Oh my God.
This is his purchase order for all of the stones,
for the base of the statue of Liberty. He's the guy,
the guy who could be the worst on America has every reason to be
at America. He builds the statue of.
This is incredible. Colonel,
please inform us at what price you can furnish during the summer of
1884, about 8,000 cubic yards of stone.
According to the sample for, to you just sat nuts. Just incredible.
So this is, this is an example. This is,
uh, early American texting. Okay. Do you know who,
um, do you know who, uh, Matt, Anthony Wayne is? I feel that I should. Okay.
He's a general on our, on the American side, in the revolution,
he was great, but he was, he was an animal. Okay.
This is a picture of him in the, uh,
in the battle of I'm trying to remember which battle the Stony point.
So Stony point, he shot in the head. Okay. He's got a bullet,
a big, huge bullet in his head and he keeps going and they're like general,
general, general. And he's like, come on, let's go.
And so they win and they, uh,
they bring him in and they're like,
we have to get the bullet out of your head. He's like,
fine, fine, but I need a piece of paper and pencil.
So this is his letter to George Washington that
says, Hey, we won. And it says, it says before, he's got the bullet.
He writes this letter and it's from Stony point 16,
July two, 2:00 AM, dear general,
the Fort and the Garrison with curl Johnstone are hours. Listen to this line,
your officers and men behaved like men who are determined to
be free. I read that line and I thought,
what does that even mean to live your life determined to be free.
Most Americans are not there. Um,
so he writes it to George Washington, George Washington, it's folded up,
George Washington then takes it.
And he puts it in his letter.
This is a letter to the governor who says, Hey,
I want to tell you about the war. Here's the Colonel's message.
So he takes this message, puts it in his letter. That's his signature? Uh, no,
it's this, it's one of these,
I think this is the Washington signature. No,
that's George Washington signature there. Yep. Very good. Does it?
He puts that letter in here. He sends it to the governor.
This is the governor's letter where he takes both of these letters.
This is texting.
Yeah. This is really American tells God that these things exist.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.